d'après ce cv votre dernier employeur
était la brasserie du homard gourmands
ça fait un peu embellie avez vous déjà
soigné une personne souffrant d'une
maladie dégénérative
pas vraiment non bon eh bien c'était un
plaisir vous avez dit pas vraiment que
vouliez-vous dire celle ci est un vrai
cauchemar
tu es réellement responsables de la vie
de quelqu'un dont avec elles n'ont pas
l'impression d'être une patiente
je sais que c'est important d'endroits
je veux juste que tout redevienne comme
avant
ma
oui
le
là des traitements expérimentaux
je suis condamné pas
à ce jour
une maison de retraite
il est loin de la vie qu'il avait bâti
ce n'est pas lui qui a eu cette maladie
qui c'est moi c'est bon t'es qui là
n'ont elles pas désolé trésor nous on va
voir ailleurs
que fais tu dans cette maison je fais
enfin quelque chose de positif
seule et unique fois que quelqu'un et ça
pourquoi tu vas mourir
et tu sais que cela n'empêcherait juste
les décombres
je veux qu ça ce que je suis désolé je
t'aime si fort
je ne sais pas ce que j'aurais s'entend